It's been a long time, Katarina. It's been a long time, Katarina
.
Oh, come to think of it, Katarina-sama won't be appearing in the theater after all.
I think you'll be happy too,
but my brother, who can't act like this, is pretty nice even if you subtract the favoritism of his relatives, but he can't
move the expression of Chan Numagaraki properly with his own will,
so yeah, that's right.
If the other party is Katarina-sama, even my brother will be able to put a smile on her face.
Hey, why don't you take a break from eating the piano because it's soothing and cute?
Come on, Boom, the
place was attractive
Kokoro-san
haha ​​g Oh prince-sama, I
'm going to have a good time [music] Not quite, even if you're someone else's husband
May 4th
me
Nicole's  wrong line